-Welcome back to the show.
A lot has happened since you've
been on the show last.
-Yes.
-Yeah, now you just became
a two-time Tony winner.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two times!
"A Strange Loop."
"A Strange Loop" is one of
the greatest musicals
I've ever seen.
Make sure you get your tickets.
-Go see "A Strange Loop."
-And go see it, yeah.
-How did you get involved with
"A Strange Loop"?
-The producer, Barbara Whitman,
called me up.
And she said she was looking for
celebrity producers.
And the story is about -- you
know, it follows a queer man's
story as he tries to sort of
figure out his way as a writer,
a musical theater writer
in show business.
And I had seen it off Broadway.
And never in a million years --
I thought it was brilliant.
Never in a million years did
I ever think it would make it
to Broadway because Broadway
didn't have things like that,
so, you know, it's such a gift
and a blessing to see
that kind of change and to see
my own personal story...
-That story be told.
-...reflected -- yes, reflected
back at me
in a Broadway musical.
It's stunning.
-It's good. It's stunning.
But it's also funny too.
-Yes.
-We've had them on the show.
The cast was just amazing.
And when you see everyone get
together, you go, "Oh, my God.
Of course, this is the best."
And it won Best Musical.
-It won Best Musical!
-Congratulations!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go see it! Go see it.
We had our pal -- Jane Fonda was
on the show the other day.
-Oh.
-And she showed us a picture of
this movie
that she's working on.
-Uh-huh.
-And it's her, Rita Moreno,
it is Lily Tomlin,
it is Sally Field.
-It is Sally Field, yes.
-And Billy Porter and Tom Brady.
-Yes.
-That's the ca--
-Yes, it is.
-That is the cast.
-[ Laughs ]
-What can you tell us?
-There are some other people
too.
Yes, it's called
"80 for Brady," and it follows
the 2016 Super Bowl, I think,
where he came back.
You know, that's not
my ministry.
[ Laughter ]
But I heard
that they came back and won.
And so, four broads
who are Tom Brady fans
win tickets to the Super Bowl
and they go to meet Tom Brady
at the Super Bowl.
And I play the
choreographer/director
of the halftime show.
I mean, who else?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait, but at the halftime show,
are you saying is there a Jane
Fonda -- is there a -- not?
-There a little bit of a moment.
There's a little bit of
a choreographic moment.
If you blink, you miss it,
but it's fun.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-I want to ask you about this
because this is
kind of exciting.
I like to be kind of
a matchmaker here on the show.
I heard that --
-Oh.
-You and J.Lo are --
You're on a mission to become
best friends with J.Lo.
[ Laughter ]
And I want to be able to --
I want to help this,
push this forward.
You want to be besties with
J.Lo. We all do.
-We can push it forward.
I -- She called me.
She reached out to me
to introduce her
for her IHeartRadio...
-Oh, yeah. She got honored.
-They were giving her
a big award.
They were honoring her.
-I actually saw this.
You did a great job.
-And so, you know, I did that
for her because,
I mean, she's J.Lo.
I mean, come on.
-Yeah.
-J.Lo calls, you answer.
-Always.
-And so, I called and we met
and we hung out.
And then she invited me
to dinner afterwards.
And Ben was there.
[ Cheers ]
And I was like,
"Oh, shoot, can we be friends?"
[ Laughter ]
And they said,
"Yes, we can be friends."
-Any projects coming up
with Jennifer?
-Not yet, but I'm trying.
-Alright, here we go.
Jennifer --
-I'm trying, girl!
You got that script, honey.
Read her after your honeymoon.
[ Laughter ]
-After the honeymoon.
You know, last time you were
on the show, I believe,
we debuted the cover of
your memoir.
-Oh, yes.
-And now it is out.
-It is out.
-People can --
[ Cheers and applause ]
People can read it.
Your story's out.
It has so many stories in here.
-Yes, there are. There's a lot.
-I was going to ask you, how do
you choose what gets in the book
and what doesn't get
into the book?
-Well, I'm an overachiever.
[ Laughter ]
-You are.
-And you know --
-You have that in common
with J.Lo.
-Yes, that's why we should be
friends.
-Exactly.
-And my editor -- you know,
I was supposed to give
like 75,000 words.
-Yeah.
-You know, true to form, I
turned in about 137,000 words.
-That's exactly right.
-And so, they were like, "We're
going to have to cut this down."
So, legal came in and stepped in
and that's how...
-They said --
-...we cut it down.
Some of the legal stuff,
they were like,
"Okay, you can't say that."
[ Laughter ]
"You can't say that.
You might get sued."
I'm like,
"Well, it's the truth."
They're like,
"Yes, it's your truth."
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But there's some unbelievable
stories in here.
-Thank you.
-It must feel good right now.
-I'm really proud of it. I am.
Go buy it!
-Yeah, go check it out.
-So we can get on "The New York
Times" bestseller list!
[ Applause ]
I'm very proud of the work.
-And now you've directed
your very first feature film.
-Yes!
-"Anything's Possible."
-On Prime Video right now.
"Anything's Possible."
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Busy, busy, busy.
-How do we set this up?
How would you set this film up
for everyone?
-Okay. So, "Anything's Possible"
is a rom-com, coming-of-age tale
in the spirit of
old John Hughes movies.
But the cast is populated with
what the world looks like today.
Our lead, our heroine is
a Black trans girl
who's a senior in high school.
She gets a boyfriend.
She gets into college.
It's about trans joy.
It's about celebration.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's about celebrating the joy.
And it's pretty magical.
-Yeah, it is.
Not only did you --
You're getting great reviews.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-But also, the soundtrack
-Has all original music.
-Yes.
-And a lot of it -- you --
-We did. I executive produced
the album with Justin Tranter
on my label, Republic Records,
where I'm actually having
my own music come out very soon,
you know, later in the fall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh!
-I call it adult pop,
so get ready.
-Adult pop?
-I'm coming! I'm coming!
-In the fall!
-And so, it's coming out.
But this is sort of
a precursor to that.
I have five brand-new songs that
I wrote with Justin Tranter
and his camp.
And we curated the album.
It's about 90%, I would say,
queer artists.
-Yeah. Good for you.
-And it's great.
So, go listen to the album.
I'm trying to bring back
the days when the album was
associated with the movie.
Remember? Y'all remember
"Waiting to Exhale"?
And, you know,
"The Preacher's Wife"
and "The Bodyguard" and stuff?
It was soundtrack!
Honey, the soundtrack
of your life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't want to make any
predictions or say anything,
but already you've won --
you won the Emmy, the Grammy.
-Yes.
-And the Tony.
-The two Tonys.
-Yes, two-time Tonys.
-So this -- I'm just saying.
You directed a great film.
You did a great soundtrack.
You sing on this.
I'm just saying, I'm ready for
an EGOT with two T's.
-Listen.
-An EGOTT. An EGOTT.
-From your lips --
-With two T's.
-From your lips to the ears
with two T's, honey.
-EGOTT.
[ Laughter ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
This is "Anything's Possible,"
directed by Billy Porter.
Take a look.
-We could live our own life
right now
or do what people expect of us
and spend the rest of our life
wondering what if.
Yes.
[ Elevator bell dings ]
♪♪
-I mean, I love that.
I love movies like that.
I love it.
-Joy. It's about joy, y'all.
-I love joy.
Speaking of joy --
-Yes.
-The cast -- I've read
some articles.
The cast have said that you're
so fun to work with on set.
And they said that in almost
every situation, you can make
any situation
into some musical moment.
And it reminds you of a song
or you'll start singing.
And you just made it
so loose and fun.
So, I thought we --
-Oh, Lord.
-We always have a spare mike...
-Oh, Lord!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-...just in case.
Is there -- Is there a song --
What are you thinking?
What are you feeling?
What would you like to express
and tell --
-Well, it's funny
you should ask.
[ Laughter ]
♪ I love it so much here
and I am telling you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I'm not going away ♪
♪ I'm staying ♪
♪ And you and you and you ♪
♪ You're gonna love meeee ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hey! ♪
♪ You're gonna loooooooooove ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Meeeeeeeeeeeeee ♪
-Are you kidding me?!
Oh, my goodness!
Look at that! Look at that!
Look at that, buddy!
Come on. Look at that!
Standing ovation.
Billy Porter.
-Thank you.
-We all need to love him.
"Anything's Possible."
That's amazing.
Streaming now, "Anything's
Possible," on Prime Video.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break, everybody.